before her I'm with her and that her is
of course Hillary Clinton it's a seminal
moment for women et's Nancy O'Dell was
with Oprah Winfrey on Wednesday in LA at
the premiere of her new own series
Greenleaf where conversation turned to
politics and Oprah revealed she's
standing with Hillary what do you think
about us
possibly having the first female
president I really believe that that is
going to happen and this is the truth
America it's about time that we made
that decision what this says is that
there is no ceiling that ceiling is when
you know it says anything is possible
yes when you can be leader of the free
world someone else lady Oh is totally on
board with James Corden he is completely
100% himself his enthusiasm is so pure
and so real I mean like I thought that
the car karaoke with all of the Broadway
stars was one of the best ever when all
of those Broadway stars are in that car
and you love Broadway I mean
you know this just means now we need
Oprah and carpool karaoke right that is
not gonna happen cuz I think you know
brah
well listen I think the whole point of
carpool karaoke is that you can sing
George Clooney and Julia Roberts cannot
sing they prove that yeah but they're
George Clooney and Julia Roberts and you
are over Winfrey oh well uh you will not
see me singing in the car that's good
darn